In this lecture sequence,
we will do a lot
with normal random variables.
And for this reason,
it is useful to start
with a simple observation
that will allow us
later on to move much faster.
Recall that a normal random
variable with a certain mean
and variance has a PDF
of this particular form.
What if somebody gives
you a PDF of this form
and asks you what
it corresponds to?
You can answer that
this is exactly
of this form provided that you
make the identification that 3
is equal to mu.
So this is a normal PDF
with a mean equal to 3
and whose variance
can also be found
by matching this constant that
appears here with the number 8.
This constant here is
in the denominator.
So we have a term
1/2 sigma squared.
This must be equal to 8.
And from this, we can
infer that the variance
of this random variable
is equal to 1/16.
And if you also want to find out
the value of this constant c,
you check the formula
for normal PDFs,
the constant c is 1 over
the standard deviation,
which is 1/4 in our case.
The square root of this number
times the square root of 2 pi.
Now suppose that somebody
gives you a PDF of this form.
It's a constant times
a negative exponential
of a quadratic function in x.
We will argue that this
PDF is also a normal PDF.
And identify the
parameters of that normal.
First, let's start with
a certain observation.
A PDF must integrate to 1 so
it cannot blow up as x goes
to infinity, which means that
this exponential needs to die
out as x goes to infinity.
And that will only happen if
this coefficient alpha here
is positive.
So that we have e to the minus
something positive and large
which is going to die out.
Therefore, we must have alpha
being a positive constant.
And let us assume from now
on that this is the case.
What we will do
next is we will try
to write this PDF in this form.
And the trick that we're
going to use is the following.
We will focus on the term
in the exponent, which
we rewrite this way.
We take out a factor of alpha.
And then we will try to
make this expression here
appear like a square of this
kind, like a perfect square.
So what is involved
is a certain method,
a certain trick called
completing the square.
That is, we write this term here
in the form x plus something
squared.
And then we may need
some additional terms.
What should that something be?
We would like that
something be such
that when we expand
this quadratic,
we get this term and that term.
Well we get an x
squared and then
there's going to
be a cross term.
What do we need here so that
the cross term is equal to this?
What we need is a term
equal to beta over 2 alpha.
Because in that
case, the cross term
is going to be 2 times x
times beta divided by 2 alpha.
The 2 in the beginning
and that 2 cancel out,
so we're left with
x beta over alpha
which is exactly
what we got here.
However, this quadratic is
going to have an additional term
which is going to be the square
of this, which is not present
here.
So to keep the two sides equal,
we need to subtract that term.
And finally, we have the
last term involving gamma.
Therefore, the PDF
of X is of the form.
We have a certain
constant from here.
Then, we have the negative
exponential of this term,
e to the minus alpha x plus
beta over 2 alpha squared.
And then there's the
negative exponential
of the rest, which is going
to be a term of the form
e to the minus alpha times beta
squared over 4 alpha squared
plus gamma over alpha.
Now this term here does
not involve any x's.
So it can be absorbed
into the constant c.
The dependence on x is
only through this term.
And now this term looks exactly
like what we've got up here,
provided that you make the
following identifications.
Mu has to be equal
to what we have here,
but here there's a minus sign,
here there's no minus sign.
And so mu is going to
be the negative of what
we have up here.
It's minus beta over 2 alpha.
And as for sigma
squared, we match
and say that 1/2 sigma squared
must be equal to the constant
that we have up
here, which is alpha.
And from this, we conclude
that sigma squared is equal
to 1/2 alpha.
So we have concluded
that a PDF of this type
is indeed a normal PDF.
It has a mean equal
to that value.
And a variance
equal to that value.
Actually, to figure out what
the mean of this PDF is,
we do not need to go
through this whole exercise.
Once we're convinced that
this is a normal PDF,
then we know that the mean is
equal to the peak of the PDF.
To find the peak, we want
to maximize this over all
x's, which is the same as
minimizing this quadratic
function over all x's.
Where is this quadratic
function minimized?
To find that place, we
can look at the exponent,
take its derivative,
and set it to 0.
So setting the derivative
of the exponent to 0
gives us the equation 2
alpha x plus beta equal to 0.
And from this, we solve for x.
And we can tell that the
peak of the distribution
is going to be when x takes
this particular value.
This value must also
be equal to the mean.
So this is a very
useful fact to know.
And we will use
it over and over.
Negative exponential of
a quadratic function of x
is always a normal PDF.